hey guys I wanted to do a video on
phosphorus to my knowledge I don't think
I've done one on this before but it's a
very important mineral because it is an
intimately involved in the formation of
energy have you heard of ATP adenosine
triphosphate okay I mean that's our
energy source that's our energy currency
in the body and we need phosphorus to
build that up also all the cell
membranes have a phospholipid membrane
okay so we need phosphorus for that your
bones need phosphorus so phosphorus
works with calcium in the body and if
you don't have enough phosphorus you get
tired you get weak bones you get joint
pain stiffness you get a calcium
deposits in the joints so when you
increase phosphorus it can help balance
out the excess calcium in the body the
best foods for phosphorus are scallops
that's number one
sardines pumpkin seeds fish shrimp cod
mushrooms eggs and meat now there is a
considerable amount of phosphorus in
grains legumes and nuts but the problem
is that you have phytic acid that locks
up the minerals that are not released
now there's an enzyme inherently in
grains called fight ace which is
supposed to neutralize this but the
problem is when you grind the grain or
you mill millet or you cook it or with
time you lose that enzyme so the
absorption of phosphorus is much much
lower so stick with these foods right
here and I think you have enough
phosphorus alright thanks for watching
hey guys I want to personally invite you
to a new Facebook group that I just
started called dr. Berg's Kido and in a
minute fasting lab ok so I created this
so we can share our successful actions
what worked what didn't work the results
so I put a link down below so go ahead
and sign up and I'll see you inside